i'm working on a vsauce video about  images and i just cut a bit from the  script that i realized i could share  right now as a short it begins with this  book that i had as a kid about the first  ladies it contains a picture of each one  except margaret taylor of her it says no  authentic likeness survives now what  fascinated me was that this wasn't a new  problem in this image of her husband on  his deathbed which was drawn while she  was alive she is depicted covering her  face why because she was so reclusive  that even then no one could be found who  knew what she looked like it is  remarkable that someone in her position  could be so  faceless both now and then but in 2010  everything changed two photographs of  her were uncovered you know the old  saying that you die twice first when  your body perishes and then again the  last time your name is said well  margaret taylor was resurrected from  what might be the third death the last  time an image of you is seen